hello everyone this game was also
suggested to me by a subscriber and as
soon as I saw the first couple of moves
I immediately recognized the game as the
first time I saw this game was probably
some 10 years ago maybe even more I
can't really remember but the idea in
this game that I used helped me win
numerous blitz games and it's definitely
something else so this was played in
1913 al Jackson was around 19 years old
at the time so this was this was a young
Alexander leave him and he's playing
against a player named radzinsky and I
couldn't find any background or
information and radzinsky so if any of
you have any information on the guy do
share in the comments but let's see this
game routine is white and alien is black
we have E 4 E 5 9 2 F 3 we have D 6 the
philidor's defense and the Rosinski goes
for Bishop to c4 we have Knight to c6 c3
Bishop to g4 by 11 Queen to b3 attacking
that f7 pawn so i can defence Queen to
d7 and now radzinsky goes for Knight to
g5 attacking f7 again and with this
Knight to g5 move Rosinski is actually
thinking that he's tricky
if he's tricking him but it's actually I
think who is tricking Rosinski
and I definitely is Knight 2 H 6 so we
have Bishop captures on f7 would check
Knight captures on f7 Knight characters
on f7 and getting of course captures
Queen captures on f7 and a lien is a
piece and threatening to exchange Queens
but radzinsky plays Queen captures on b7
and it seems that white managed to trick
black as now the Queen is attacking this
rook and a 8 also this knight on c6 and
well things are looking pretty grim for
black but this move I reckon the next
move is try to try and find it find it
on your own but again his next move is
simply I don't know I have no words how
to describe it
I even plays King to d7 and this is this
is the idea after I saw this
I've actually used it a couple of times
in my games and what's why I gonna do
here obviously the night is no longer
available available for capture but wise
can capture the rock and they ate and he
does maybe have some idea on what aliens
plan here is but if he doesn't capture
the rock what can he play he can play a
queen to be five maybe and well this
would allow black to simply to simply
develop all the pieces Bishop e7 h5
maybe Ruby 8 is coming with a temple on
the Queen this would be very enjoyable
for black so after this King 37 move her
things he captured the rook so Queen
captures on a8 and here as I can
instantly goes Queen to c4 and is
threatening checkmate Ani - the King has
nowhere to go
Bishop is covering d1 Queen is covering
f1 and how do you defend this well only
move it seems is f3 so two things could
place it he goes f3 and I think in place
Bishop captures on f3 and again 11 is a
threatening checkmate
un'ytu so G captures on f3 and now
another beautiful idea by I definitely
plays Knight to d4 and again elation is
threatening checkmate here on e2 and
Aliens idea is that if if this pawn
captures night then Queen captures
Bishop would check and Queen captures
rook on h1 and this would be okay for
black but this was actually a White's
best defense but Rosinski finds another
idea and again he tries to trick ali-a
him he plays d3 with the idea if Queen
captures pawn then the knight can be
captured as Queen can no longer capture
the bishop and c1 so idea he captures
that Queen captures on d3 and of course
now Rosinski thinks he has a free night
so seek after 74 and now comes aliens
the greatest idea
he plays Bishop to e7 and this is this
is devastating ian is a threatening
Bishop to h4 with checkmate and this is
this can be stopped because well he's
also attacking Rosinski Queen and the
only way white can stop a Bishop to h4
checkmate is to play nice to d2 so after
so
again plays Bishop page for now king d1
is available but if radzinsky will play
Knight to d2 then simply rook captures
Queen and the game is over so I'm sure
radzinsky thought this was well this was
just the wasting time and routine scree
plays Queen captures on h8 grabbing
another rook and allowing a lien to
finish the game with this beautiful move
Bishop to h4 checkmate so yeah
definitely an amazing position as you
can see Black has only a queen and the
bishop but he has he has two developed
pieces White has a queen a rook a knight
a bishop
another rook but none of his pieces are
developed so this will make you think
about being materialistic over over you
know developing your pieces so yeah
thank you for suggesting such a
beautiful game and I do hope you all
enjoyed it as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here and thank you
all for watching and I will see you soon